-Orlando.
It is great to see you.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
-Thank you for having me.
It's always a pleasure
to see you, Jimmy.
These un-- surreal
and new circumstances.
-It really is.
I'm happy that you're safe.
How have you --
How is life in the quarantine?
-To be honest, it's been --
So, I was working a lot,
and I've found some real solace
and real kind of --
I think it's a reset.
Everyone feels like it's a reset
that perhaps we all needed,
the chance to reflect
on what's important
and what we've been doing
in the --
And I just hope that, you know,
we can keep that --
That thinking can kind of
continue on past and through
once there are vaccines in place
and people want to go
about their lives.
I understand it's, like, just --
I mean,
feel incredibly blessed.
Obviously you're in New York,
and there are people
who probably for weeks on end
couldn't even get out
of their apartments, right?
-It was rough.
-So I've been --
I've been feeling very grateful.
Obviously, I have a little
baby girl on the way.
-We got to talk about that.
I am so excited for you
to have a baby girl.
I have two girls.
-That's -- It's amaz--
Well, you'll have to
tell me all about it.
I'm so excited to be --
to have a little daddy's girl.
I hope -- I hope
she's going to love me
as much as I love her.
But that daddy-girl thing
and, you know...
That "love of your life"
feeling,
I think, is right around there,
you know?
-It's exactly
what everyone tells you.
So no spoilers from me.
But it really is
love at first sight,
and then it just doesn't end,
and it's just like --
It's the best thing in the world
to just even watch them grow up
in every little thing.
It's just like -- It's so cute.
I mean, boys -- cute, too.
Sons are great.
Obviously you know that.
They're great.
But the girls.
-I got a 9-year-old boy, yeah.
So --
-You get the little --
-He's got a couple
of other brothers,
but this is his first sister,
so he's excited, too.
So it's exciting times.
-Oh, it's -- Yeah.
Is that your work behind you
or is that your son's Lego work?
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah!
-This is hours of quarantine.
Quarantining.
-Those are Legos?
-Those are Legos.
I actually found it
kind of reassuring,
and, obviously --
Actually, me and Flynn
started with this big silver
Porsche up here.
-Yeah.
-And I got so into it.
He would, like, go, "Dad,
I'm going to go to bed.
I'm like,
"Just another 15 minutes."
-"Let me stay up. Please let me
stay up a little longer."
-"Just do the next page. We'll
open the next bag. Come on."
-"You're my dad." Yeah. You can
stay up as long as you like.
What's the green one up there?
What's the green one
on the top corner there?
-That's a Defender 90.
A Land Rover Defender 90.
-I didn't even know
they made these Legos.
-Oh, man, neither did I.
Now I'm just like --
There's another Porsche.
There's like a --
I mean, like this is...
1967 Ch--
I mean, you know, it's just fun.
-Wow!
-It's just hours of fun.
But, um --
-Well, as you were
saying before,
you were filming "Carnival Row."
I think that was the last time
you were in studio with us,
filming your show
"Carnival Row."
Congrats. You got three
Emmy nominations, bud.
-Thanks, man. Yeah, no.
Everyone's worked so hard
on that show.
It was -- The first season
was not straightforward
in so many ways, but I think
we really kind of brought
an interesting story
to the screen,
so I'm happy that
we're going back to finish.
-Yeah. Congrats on the noms.
I wanted to talk to you
about something because --
We always talk
about giving back,
and we were talking right before
we started this interview.
But you do a lot of work
with UNICEF.
-Yeah.
-What's your connection
with UNICEF?
-It's been about 10 years.
Or more actually. Maybe 12.
But I've done --
I was trying to do basically
one field trip every year
just to sort of witness,
really, firsthand the work
that they do in the field
to save the lives
of women and children
in the most desperate
circumstances.
And then what we will do
is video document it,
and obviously it's an NGO,
so we're trying to put
the messaging out to
hopefully people to support,
because, you know, obviously,
the world is suffering
from this global pandemic,
you know, and when we look
at the way we feel at home,
you kind of imagine that
and then times it
by 10 or even more.
UNICEF's on the ground right now
all over the world, you know,
trying to get PPE equipment
to people, to vaccinate.
There are vaccinations
outside --
I mean, water is a huge killer.
So they need to inoculate for
children under the age of 2.
Diarrhea is a huge killer.
There are so many huge issues.
Then you add
that COVID element on top.
So it's something that
is very close to my heart,
you know, to see these children,
and I've worked with them
so many times.
And, you know, they're always
looking for support.
UNICEF's always looking
for that support because --
Obviously,
it's so challenging at home,
but it's also, you know,
having the foresight
that we are a global community.
We are a global community.
And when one part of
that community is suffering,
the whole -- the whole suffers.
And just kind of grappling
with that idea
is sometimes challenging,
but it's something
that's so, you know, amazing
when you see it.
-Well, thanks so much
for talking about it
and getting people
talking about it.
-Thanks for asking, honestly.
I've been watching your show
a little bit,
and it's great to see
that you guys are kind of
highlighting people's causes
'cause it's something that --
We all want to have something
that we can do
to give back in some way.
-That's the least
we can do, right?